iron man is my son's absolute favorite
avenger he is always asking me why i am
the worst avenger and why couldn't i be
iron man
i mean that that's amazing
i mean amazing and uh
i mean i i i think the interview could
end on that like
that's the quote of the day
right
why are you the worst avenger and why
can't you be iron man
amazing um so jumping on in um uh
obviously i have a ton of questions
about south of heaven but i like
throwing some curve balls at the
beginning um i want to know what do you
remember about being a student in freddy
vs jason
i remember um i remember some a couple
people got trampled in the corn scene
when everybody's running through the
cornfields like in terror i don't even
know what we were running from to be
honest i assume it's freddy or jason who
knows could have been either of them but
people got trampled
um
i remember
uh
i remember
because i was a student at the time and
i did extra work to pay my way through
university so my thing was i was i was
always trying to get to the back of the
scene so that they wouldn't need to use
me for half of the setups and i could go
back to the extras holding and study
and they kept putting me in this front
of the scene right beside the lead
actors and i was like i am never gonna
get my work done
and then now my imdb page um credits me
as an actor in that movie which is
really irritating because i was not an
actor in that movie i was an extra in
that movie they've done that with a
bunch of my extra work and so
instead of um
my first credit being lost it's probably
freddie versus jason as things stand on
imdb
i think i think there's a few but i
listen i uh i uh
i totally get it but you know other
people were dreaming about getting to
the front of the camera you're like
[Laughter]
no i wanted to get my physics homework
done that's what i wanted to do
completely um so how often do people
want to talk to you about real steel
um real steel by the way did you know
that today is the 10th anniversary of
real steel
i shouldn't i should know that but i
didn't
um entertainment weekly has just
released this beautiful um like
uh like what is it called like a
oral history
yeah in oral history that's exactly it
yeah
so i just actually finished doing a
beautiful interview with them and the
main cast of the of the film
it is a beloved
beloved movie people who are fans of it
are die-hard fans of it um and there's a
lot of them when i when i go to cons
it's one of my favorite things is when
people come up and they're like instead
of it being about lost or the hobbit or
marvel like yeah i love real steel
that's one because i love real steel as
an audience member it's one of my
favorite films i've ever done
so jumping into south of heaven uh what
what i know you're basically you are
pretty selective with the projects you
take on um you know uh at least it looks
like that you know i guess i'm curious
what was it about this material that
said uh i want to do this
um
there were a couple things one was aaron
koscielny is the director he's an
israeli director who had directed a film
called big bad wolves i don't know if
you've ever seen it but it's amazing
and i it's not the kind of film i would
normally watch i don't watch thrillers i
don't watch horrors i don't like violent
movies and it is about homicidal
pedophile i mean there is nothing more
offensive to me that i would normally
turn it off within the first five
minutes but he handled it with such
wit and sensitivity and sweetness and
beauty that i was like
this guy is doing something really
really special i think he's kind of a
master in that space of handling like
high gore high violence with such grace
and um he also creates great characters
and annie the character that i play in
south of heaven was a character that i
was very excited to play i was very
excited to throw off the mantle of tough
and capable kick-ass chick
and
play a soft and sweet
and sensitive and gracious woman
who is dying
and despite dying of being you know
having about a year to live because
she's dying of lung cancer
um being a total ray of light to the
world that she inhabits um and when i
was doing my research for the project
there was um a blogger named lynya olson
who blogs on um outliving cancer doc no
outliving
outliving
lungcancer.com and she became my
inspiration for annie and um you know
her cover picture is like
absolutely glowing with light and joy
and vibrance and yet in her blog post
you see her go through these really kind
of uh huge ups and downs of of um a huge
emotional spectrum of sort of where it
takes her facing death all the time
and so um this character was really a
huge driving force for me i wanted to
play her and then who doesn't want to
work with jason sudeikis who doesn't
want to work with ted lasso i mean he
wasn't ted lasso back then when we made
the film
but he was actually in the process of
making ted lasso at the time remember he
would be on set and he'd be working on
the editing for this show he'd worked on
the uk
and he was so passionate about it and he
was so invested in it but nobody had
seen it yet and now i'm a die-hard fan
but i was already a fan of jason's
before that
i really like the scene where um you
guys are uh it's when you're first
together you get into the house and both
of you guys are nervous about each other
and about you know being
intimate and you know because it's been
12 years uh and i did hear that you were
instrumental in that scene being
rewritten to be more like that than just
you know him you joining him in the
bathtub if you will um
so can you sort of talk about that scene
because i thought it was very honest and
real
yeah um
i wish i was i wish i would be able to
um
remember the title of the film
that was an inspiration for that for me
and so aaron cosellis based this film
off of the old 60s and 70s thrillers and
he's a huge fan of those movies so i did
a little bit of research and he had me
watch a couple of them
and one of them
i wish i could remember the title it's
gonna drive me crazy now because i will
not be able to come up with it but
maybe you'll know there's a convict who
comes out of prison and then him and his
gal are kind of on the run together and
um she
she was such a big star back then
brunette absolutely dropped it gorgeous
she was probably only like 19 when she
did the roll
it's not fake no i i won't know i mean i
should know but there's so many choices
it's totally i know there's too many
there's exactly that's exactly right but
basically um the way the scene was
originally written was very
um classic
southern guy
being like smarmy and flirty and like
come on honey let's like hook up
and her being like classically kind of
shy and demure in her lingerie like
kind of feel a little bit shy because i
haven't been with you in 12 years i just
said to aaron we can't we can't do that
that doesn't represent anybody's reality
i don't think i think after 12 years in
prison and after having completely
destroyed his and annie's life and
future together i don't think this guy
would be coming in with you know
he wouldn't be coming in balls first he
would be coming in with a lot of pain
and shame and guilt and anger and
frustration and and i don't know that
intimacy is that easy when you first
come out of prison i i don't have that
experience but if i were to imagine
what that reentry period must be like
for couples it's
it's got to be a challenge for a lot of
them and i thought it would be much more
interesting to represent that version of
reality where um
actually the woman has to take the lead
and she takes the lead not so much
because she's horny she takes the lead
because she
has so much grace for what he's done and
how he imploded their life and um and
aaron aaron went for it and said i
really i want to do that and i'm really
i'm really happy with where this scene
ended up
oh no it's very real and honest um i've
been given the wrap-up signal but do you
mind if i just ask one other question
really yeah of course i'm
tatum can we take a few more minutes i
talk so much sometimes you know it's
i i just
yeah no i no it's just because um as you
can tell by the things behind me oh by
the way i didn't even realize you're
sure
oh my god
[Music]
it didn't even occur to me till just now
that that
but as you can tell by certain things
that are behind me uh i am a little bit
of a marvel fan and i really do want to
ask you uh if you can tease anything
about the ant-man movie that i believe
you might be filming
i i can tease that i am currently
filming quantum mania
and um i can tease nothing else for you
lest i die
sure can i at least ask you what was
your reaction uh after reading the
script was it one of these things where
you were just like
if you could talk about that i would be
happy to i was so stoked on the script
jeff loveness is our new writer for the
for the film and we've never worked with
him before
and i think he is phenomenal i think
he's one of the best writers we've ever
had i think he's got an incredible
mastery of voice so on the page i could
hear all the characters and and i knew
that he really kind of harnessed
each person's unique personality and um
and i just think that it's gonna be
it's it's gonna be really special i
think it's gonna be really good i
actually think it has the chance to be
the best one we've done yet
yeah i can't i cannot wait my last thing
for you um do you actually pay attention
to all the other no it's not about
ant-man uh
you know i just love the genuine
enthusiasm i can feel it
oh yeah no i actually really care about
the stuff the but i'm curious do you
actually watch all the other marvel
things the animation i know you did what
if are you watching all this to sort of
make sure that you're like
in the loop as if you understand
everything that's going on are you
almost watching it now because you
mentioned you have a son who is a fan
are you now watching everything like
with your son and sort of taking it in
through his eyes in a completely new way
a bit of both and a bit of neither i i
have not seen all of it and i and i do
try i sort of i see it as almost like
homework like i i need to i need to know
what's going on in the world i need to
understand when there's references made
in scripts you know i need to know
what's going on um i'm also a fan of
marvel
as in i'm a fan of the filmmakers that
that are you know creating this
incredible universe i think
they are the best superhero movie makers
i've ever witnessed i and i know that
i'm not alone in that so that's not a
revolutionary thing to say except that i
don't actually like superhero movies so
coming from me
that's different i i think they're
really smart i think they're really
really really good at what they do and
it's why i wanted to get involved with
this franchise um you know i never had
any desire to be in a superhero movie
but marvel do it right they do it really
well so i'm a fan like i i think wanda
vision was
phenomenal and i think it was
probably the best they've ever
represented a female character it was so
incredible to see her be so complicated
and so flawed and yet so redeemable and
so lovable um the way we have typically
historically treated our male characters
i think it was an epic female
protagonist story
um i loved
loved the ending of loki the loki tv
show i they didn't fully have me till
the end i was like okay okay sure yeah
okay it's good but i wasn't like oh my
god this is the amazing show until they
got to the end and i was like it's chaos
theory i love it i love it i love it you
loves that element of how smart they are
and how they tackle such enormous topics
that
most kind of fluff popcorn movies are
not going to tackle
they tackled chaos theory that's really
brave and really bold and really cool um
so yeah i don't watch them all i still
haven't seen my one f episode which i'm
dying to see because i had so much fun
making it but i will i'll catch up on it
eventually i still haven't seen black
widow but i will i i'm you know i have
intentions to i haven't seen the
uh
what's anthony mackie's show called
falcon and winter soldier yes i haven't
seen falcon winter soldier yet i will
you know i just it takes there's so many
things i can't i but i've definitely not
seen them all i actually had one
division and local are the only tv shows
i've seen from marvel
yeah i i i mean i could just dig deep on
this but i'll just say that with loki i
agree with you that ending is amazing
because jonathan majors is telling them
the truth that and it's just this great
and he's so good in it um and he's
telling them you know you might get
someone a lot worse than me like you
you're you know what i mean it's so good
it's so good and the fact that
when when we explore the two sides to
chaos theory it's two sides of the same
person is so
good because i don't know about you but
i have both those people in me i mean i
have that constant battle inside of me
especially right now with the way the
world is today of like
how much do we control and how much do
we need freedom and where is that
balance and what does that look like and
what's more important safety or freedom
and and that's what they're tackling in
this show and the fact that tackling it
in 2021 postpending well
mid pandemic
you know is is really
brave and bold and um
yeah i dig it
you